con la invasión de rusia a ucrania son
muchos los ciudadanos que están
dispuestos a resistir hasta el punto de
armarse con rifles y fusiles para hacer
frente a las tropas rusas
definitivamente estoy en contra de la
guerra así que espero que termine antes
de que tenga que usar mi arma contra
humanos pero por si acaso dado que es mi
tierra la defender y proteger a mi
familia mi casa mis seres queridos
robots y es que ahora el día a día de
los ucranianos gire en torno a la guerra
esta antigua fábrica de cerveza del pib
ahora se dedica a producir y distribuir
cócteles mólotov en los últimos días ha
distribuidos cientos de ellos por toda
la ciudad para reforzar las defensas
civiles locales
distance producimos bastantes miles de
hecho proporcionamos a las fuerzas de
defensa territorial locales para que
estuvieran preparados en caso de que los
soldados y los tanques rusos y eran acá
y también enviamos a algunos aquí y en
las diferentes ciudades en las que
necesitan resistir las operaciones
militares
el ejército ruso es el segundo más
poderoso del mundo el de ucrania ocupa
el número 22 es inferior con menos
vehículos militares y artillería motivo
por el que el presidente de volodymyr
felinski pidió a los ciudadanos que se
armarán
música tenemos para proteger nuestra
tierra seguiremos entregando armas a
todos los que sean dispuestos a tomarlas
a todos los que están dispuestos a
proteger nuestra seguridad en este
másters no obstante diferentes
organizaciones advierten de los dilemas
éticos sobre armar a civiles debido al
alto riesgo de enfrentarse a un ejército
profesional y bien armado